[Music]
Jemima you asked a really interesting
question do the tides affect the water
in our body now the simple answer is no
but let's talk about why that's true the
tides are caused every day by the moon
and the Sun stretching the earth the
gravity actually stretches the earth
apart just a little bit now the earth is
a very large object but think about
smaller things now do you haven't
noticed tides on a lake for a very large
lake like the Great Lakes there might be
a little bit of a tidal difference every
day but it's actually kind of hard to
measure what a smaller lake or a pond
what about something like a swimming
pool I think even in your own experience
you can see that smaller objects don't
really have any tidal differences across
the day and that's just because of the
size as we said the tides are caused by
the gravity of the moon and the Sun
stretching the earth but now take it
down to a really really tiny scale over
really small scales that just isn't much
of an effect you really can't sense it
at all it just becomes unimportant now
the interesting thing is that this would
not be the case if we were around
something like a black hole if you were
around a black hole which is a dead star
and say the mass of the black hole was
about 20 times the mass of the Sun a
black hole like that is actually not
very physically large you have all that
mass but the black hole itself may only
be now stay on the order of about 30
miles across that means you have all
that mass packed into a tiny little area
if you were near by a black hole that
means there really would be a detectable
gravity stretching across something as
small as your body and not just the
water in your body would feel that as
you got closer and closer to a black
hole you would actually feel your head
stretched away from your feet there
would be tidal forces just like the
earth goes through with the Sun and the
moon but next to a black hole the
gravity is so extreme
there would be tides over something as
small as a human body get closer and
closer to a black hole and your head
keeps getting stretched more and if you
keep taking stretch that way and you
could actually turn you into a stream
particles scientists have a really cool
name for this it's called
spaghettification from the word
spaghetti if you got close to a black
hole there would be tides over your body
that's small that would rip you apart
into basically a strand of spaghetti
that would fall down the black hole
[Music]